Можна з'їсти шоколадку,
а можна проїхатись на велосипеді.
І це теж дасть можливість
відчувати щастя.
Велосипед робить життя
в місті кращим.
Велосипедні вулиці
більш приємні для життя.
Там менше шумового забруднення,
там краще повітря.
Вони більш приємні для прогулянок.
Вони більш безпечні для всіх,
не лише для велосипедистів.
Там краще розвивається
дрібна торгівля, кав'ярні.
Вони більш живі,
вони більш приємні.
U-Cycle — це експертна громадська
членська організація,
яка займається саме розвитком
велосипедної інфраструктури,
просуває, промотує велосипедний
транспорт та підвищує безпеку руху.
Організація вже існує понад 14 років.
Була створена як реагування
на резонансне смертельне ДТП,
яке сталось тоді в Києві
з велосипедистом,
щоби адвокатувати
велосипедну інфраструктуру,
зробити велосипед безпечним, комфортним
транспортом не лише для Києва,
а й для всіх урбанізованих територій.
І, власне, велосипед для нас — інструмент
оцих позитивних міських трансформацій.
Ми ведемо дуже системну
роботу на різних рівнях.
Ми працюємо на національному рівні,
і також ми працюємо на локальному рівні.
Є кілька стратегічних напрямків.
Перший — це адвокація велосипедного
транспорту і безпеки руху.
Другий — це розвиток
мережі агентів змін.
І третій напрямок — це, власне, промоція
велосипеда як транспорту і безпеки руху.
І тут ми проводимо багато
дуже різних заходів:
велошкола з безпеки руху, велопарад дівчат у Києві,
флешмоб «Велосипедом на роботу».
Чути мене?
Хочемо показати вам,
чому ми починаємо цю екскурсію
від пам'ятника Богдану Хмельницькому.
Тому що 2013 року в Києві Асоціація велосипедистів
Києва запустила соціальну рекламу,
яка називалася «Київ — велосипедне місто».
Це новий наш формат — авторські тури
людей з нашої спільноти на різні теми.
Це така поїздка на кілька годин
цікавим маршрутом з розповіддю велогіда.
Зараз їдемо по Рейтарській [вулиці].
По велосмузі.
Там, де це можливо.
У нас є команда офісу,
на сьогодні це десять людей.
Координатори різних програм, напрямків.
Є ще рада.
І є ще в нас люди —
члени організації і наші велоактивісти.
Власне, наші велоактивісти часто
є активістами в різних інших темах.
Тому що це ті люди,
які більше бачать проблеми міста.
Вони його більше люблять.
І, відповідно, ти виходиш
на всі акції підтримки,
ініціюєш проєкти
на громадський бюджет.
Тобто ти, власне, більш активний
учасник цього міста.
До Майдану в нас було
близько 100 членів організації.
Коли стався Майдан,
до кінця року в нас було 300.
Тобто це був просто колосальний бум.
І якраз після Революції
багато хто включився:
вперше поволонтерив,
став активним.
Побачили, що коли ми об'єднуємось,
ця спільнота може робити зміни.
В українських ПДР велосипедист —
це повноправний учасник дорожнього руху.
Але коли ми входили...
Наприклад, п'ять років тому, вийшовши на наші вулиці,
складно було це помітити.
Тому що нічого не сигналізує,
що велосипедист тут повноправний.
Ми порівняли, як це в Європі,
зібрали кращі досвіди.
І на основі опитування на різних рівнях
в Україні оцього локального контексту
ми поєднали і запропонували,
напрацювали наші пропозиції
до змін правил дорожнього руху.
Щоб зробити створення велосипедної інфраструктури
в українських містах можливим.
А по-друге, зробити
цю нормативну базу якісною,
такою, як в західноєвропейських містах.
Кабмін ухвалив ці зміни,
пройшло три роки.
Буває дуже швидка адвокація.
Наприклад, ми дізнаємося,
що Укрзалізниця змінює правила перевезень.
І, виявляється, що вони викидають з потягів
«Інтерсіті» право перевозити вело.
Було буквально кілька тижнів на коментування
правил перевезення Укрзалізниці.
Топ-менеджмент Укрзалізниці
нас покликав на переговори.
Ми прийшли з пропозиціями,
ми підготувалися.
А вони кажуть: «А де-де?
Ми думали, що в нас буде акція протесту!
Де ваші колеги,
чого немає під Укрзалізницею?».
Вони очікували,
що ми прийдемо з протестами,
будемо просто кричати: «Проти!».
І я дуже щаслива.
Я буквально кілька тижнів тому
подорожувала до батьків.
Це приміське сполучення.
І я потрапила в новий вагон,
і там були кріплення для велосипедів,
цілий майданчик.
І там було кріплення для шести
велосипедів, таких вертикальних.
І я просто знаю,
що це є наслідок того,
що два роки тому ми сходили на залізницю,
на зустріч, і запропонували це.
Зараз тільки розробляється
національна велосипедна стратегія.
От ми якраз ініціювали цей процес.
Міністерство інфраструктури
має її затвердити.
А на національному рівні
до цього часу нічого,
жоден документ не підтримував
розвиток велотранспорту.
Відповідно, всі міста сьогодні,
які якось просунулись,
це були персональні
ініціативи цих міст.
Сьогодні, наприклад, уже Вінниця, Львів
мають досить великі мережі.
По 100 і більше кілометрів.
От Київ, фактично, їх наздогнав
тільки цього року.
Київ ніколи не стане Амстердамом.
Наші міста мають свою
унікальність напрацювати.
На рівні Києва ми адвокатуємо
реалізацію велосипедної концепції,
за яку кілька років тому проголосували
депутати Київради одноголосно.
І це було для нас
дуже великою перемогою.
Тобто ми включаємося
в бюджетний процес, ми ходимо на...
Ми моніторимо всі реконструкції,
ремонти вулиць,
ми ходимо на наради в департамент
транспортної інфраструктури.
Зараз вже такий етап, коли Київ почав
активно створювати велоінфраструктуру.
І для нас важливо моніторити,
де вона з'являється,
бо велодоріжки мають з'являтися
не там, де їх можуть робити,
а там, де вони справді потрібні.
Найбільша проблема — Кирилівська.
Тому з нею зараз ніхто нічого робити не хоче
і наступного року точно не буде.
— Це тому що проєкту немає, так?
— Так.
Що ще? Проблема з Подолом.
Ніхто ще не знає....
Не прийнято фінальне рішення,
куди цей новий міст будуть пускати.
Ми робимо підрахунок
велосипедистів в Києві.
Це, власне, єдиний сьогодні
моніторинг взагалі велотрафіку.
Ми за сім років зібрали великі дані:
як змінюється взагалі портрет
київського велосипедиста,
які вулиці люди обирають.
Це один із найстаріших
велотреків Європи.
Він був побудований 1913 року.
Тоді тут проводилися змагання,
але не лише [вони].
Тут був літній кінотеатр
«Полярна зірка».
Тут показували кіно, була кінорубка
[приміщення технологічного забезпечення кінопоказу],
і був свій оркестр.
Взагалі, це було громадське місце.
До речі, як і зараз,
після відновлення велотреку.
Тут є кафе, тут є сквер.
І, як ви бачите, тут зараз
є якась штука для дітей.
Крім цього, у них
є велошкола для дітей.
Зазвичай, якщо подивитися,
де в Києві відбуваються ДТП,
вони часто відбуваються
в одних і тих самих місцях.
Відповідно, місто має більш активно
звертати увагу і швидко там щось міняти.
Наші міста мають так розвиватися,
наші вулиці мають так
ремонтуватися, проєктуватися,
має бути нульова толерантність
до смерті на дорозі.
І ця концепція має цілий ряд заходів інфраструктурних,
інженерних, різного законодавчого характеру.
Наша ціль така, щоб велосипед
був доступним для всіх:
для дітей їхати в школу, для жінок.
Бо, наприклад, сьогодні
жінок не більше 15%.
А, наприклад, в Берліні чи в тому ж Амстердамі
жінок приблизно порівно з чоловіками.
Це не про те, що там такі всі жінки,
що хочуть їздити на велосипедах.
Це про те, що жінка на велосипеді —
це індикатор безпеки.
Якщо в нашому місті буде 30% і більше
відсотків жінок на велосипеді,
це говоритиме про те, що велосипед
стає безпечним і зручним.
Є таке поняття,
яке ми намагаємося популяризувати,
зокрема, одним із заходів,
який називається «Велопарад дівчат».
Це поняття називається
[англійською] «велосипедний шик».
Це не про шик
в розумінні українською мовою.
Це не про стрази, блискітки і боа.
Це про повсякденну вуличну моду.
[англійською] Київський «велосипедний шик» —
це гештег велопараду дівчат вже багато років.
І мета велопараду дівчат,
окрім того, щоби показати запит
на безпечну велоінфраструктуру,
це ще й популяризувати велосипед
як вид транспорту, доступний для всіх.
Ми проводили десять років у Києві
велошколу з безпеки руху.
Це волонтерська ініціатива,
де всі охочі,
які приходили на заняття,
могли пройти цей урок з ПДР.
Це теорія і практична поїздка
містом з велотренером.
Ми не навчаємо людей їздити з нуля.
До нас приїжджають люди,
які вже вміють крутити педалі,
але ще невпевнено почуваються
в місті на велосипеді.
Ми хочемо інтегрувати цей велоурок
з безпеки руху в шкільну програму.
І зробити її доступною для всіх дітей,
учнів шкіл по всій Україні.
У нас смертність дитяча і підліткова
найвища якраз в ДТП.
Відповідно, ми сподіваємося,
що не лише інфраструктура,
а й освіта, просвіта також
допоможуть рятувати життя.
У Києві 2020 року стався
справжній велобум.
Коли закрили метро, багато людей просто
не мали можливості чимось добиратися.
І якраз велосипед став справді опцією.
Тоді запустився якраз
і міський велопрокат.
І карантин дуже показав,
що велосипед може бути в Києві,
по-перше, транспортом,
по-друге, в два з половиною рази
зросла кількість велосипедистів.
Змінився дуже рівень дискусії.
І я неймовірно тому щаслива.
Бо я люблю для себе, це моє таке хобі,
трекати [відслідковувати] зміни.
Не стоїть питання:
«Велосипед: транспорт чи ні?».
Дискусія вже про кращі рішення.
Ага, нам підходить нідерландська
школа проєктування чи німецька?
І от, власне, мене це дуже радує.
Ми переконані,
що конкретно у своєму місті
зміни можуть робити люди,
які на місці,
які там живуть.
Тобто нам складно бути в Києві
і робити зміни в Коломиї.
Ми кілька років тому стали співзасновниками
«Української велосипедної мережі».
Сьогодні там понад 20 велосипедних
організацій з різних міст.
У деяких містах, насправді,
не завжди це велоорганізації.
Іноді це одна-дві людини.
І от можливість бути
доєднаним до мережі,
доєднаним до якоїсь більшої
спільноти, дуже підтримує.
Проводимо щороку міжнародну
конференцію «Велофорум».
Вона щороку в різних містах,
і міста виборюють право
приймати «Велофорум».
І часто конференція стає потужним
імпульсом для розвитку вело.
І от сьогодні ми прийшли в точку,
де вже ми можемо
говорити про велотуризм.
Щоб це було більш доступно і приємно
для більшої кількості людей.
Тобто також мають бути якісь
інфраструктурні речі, навігація.
Тобто це має бути зрозуміло,
більш комфортно, зручно.
Україна поки що [латиною] невідома
земля для іноземців.
Та й для багатьох українців
[латиною] невідома земля також.
І велосипед це чудовий...
Я для себе свого часу відкрила
зовсім інакший Крим.
Я, мабуть, 2011 чи 2012 року
придбала велосипед,
бо я дуже хотіла
в тижневу подорож.
Таку, по «хардкору»:
з наметом тощо.
Це була Арабатська стрілка до Керчі.
Наступного року вже був
Джарилгач і західний берег.
2014 року я мала проїхати південний
берег і замкнути цю лінію.
Але сталася анексія,
і, власне...
Це залишається моєю мрією: замкнути
берегову лінію Криму на велосипеді.
Я не дуже вірю в ідеальний світ,
але вірю в те, що світ
можна покращувати.
І наша організація —
хороший приклад того,
що громадянське суспільство в Україні
може бути результативним.
Тобто робити реальні зміни
на національному, на локальному рівнях.
Для мене особисто працювати тут — це можливість
інвестувати мій час та енергію в те,
що справді дає зміни.
Коли ти не чекаєш, що хтось.
Хоча ти й усвідомлюєш,
що є інституції і вони мають працювати.
Але ти також маєш бути активним.
І це не про перекладання
відповідальності,
а про активне залучення
всіх в різних ролях.
І громадська організація —
це одна з опцій.
Я бачу, що Україна насправді
дуже класно змінюється.
І дуже багато в нас проблем
і дуже болісних питань.
Але те, що країна міняється...
І завдяки активним людям,
які вірять у цю країну.
Тому для мене Україна
про цих прекрасних людей,
які, власне, вірять у цю країну.
І роблять все можливе,
щоб вона змінювалася на краще.